you know you know i was i was wondering
um i've read a lot about how certain
places have like really high crime like
i hear west virginia has a lot of high
crime and like these a lot of these
places
outside of cities have high crime they
say new york has low crime and i'm like
why is it then that people in west
virginia
there's like not many police around and
then why like you know and people just
get along just fine or get by just fine
then why is it in new york there's like
we're hearing these massive spike and
murders and things like this
wasn't some guy just beaten and stripped
naked in the street in new york
yeah i remember probably yeah there's a
video of it
yeah yeah yeah i mean i've seen stuff
like that in real life
in new york city growing up i've seen
crazy
things that would spark people's ptsd if
i described what i saw growing up
and uh this is from uh six to six i'm
sorry this is i want to pull this up
six hours ago man seen stripped and
beaten in new york city
attack was known gang member with
lengthy criminal history
victim is expected to survive so why the
26 year old victim
was in the area of canal and allen
around 11 30 a.m on friday when the
group of about a dozen men and women
jumped him and took a cell phone pants
undergarments and shoes
they then used a sharp object to slice
him in the head hands and torso
the victim was taken to a local hospital
where he's expected to survive
on monday the police commissioner
dermate released a 50-second video
of what he called a brazen broad
daylight attack the footage shows the
man running away from the group
as they catch up and begin beating him
police sources told the new york post
the victim lives in brooklyn
and had just returned from atlanta the
violent crew had reportedly been staking
out the nearby bus stop for the man's
arrival
police said they fled in several
vehicles after the attack a law
enforcement source confirmed to fox news
the victim had been linked
to the violent mack baller brims gang
if the shoe was on the other foot he'd
be part of that gang the sword
source said so is it it's just gang
violence i guess yeah
this is an interesting thing like
chicago is an interesting gun
conversation chicago's got a bunch of
people with illegal guns and they go
around shooting each other all the time
and i think that's what the left uses an
argument for gun control
criminals who take the guns and then are
causing problems and murdering people
over the place
i guess for me i've always kind of
wondered if the guns are already illegal
and they're committing murders with them
why would passing a law stop them from
committing a murder which is already
illegal i mean like that's the worst
crime
yeah well we're killing somebody we see
a lot of deliberations one of the worst
crimes we see a lot of liberals talk
about gun
homicides and they keep forgetting that
most of them are from
illegal guns and jurisdictions that
already ban them
other gun deaths are because of suicide
and then i think
the third highest level of gun death
rates are from police officers shooting
people
so so if you're for you know gun control
you're not really for gun control you're
for
having individuals with guns take away
other people's guns at the threat of
using guns that's essentially what
you're for and you should just be honest
about it that you want people
robbed of their ability to defend
themselves while of course the
politicians
want literal machine guns protecting
them all the time
i like the the idea of having an armed
society is kind of cool because
if if some group does rise up to
overthrow the government with guns which
lake and holland they're probably afraid
of
you have the rest of the population also
armed to protect the country
from the overthrow civil war well
ideally
i mean that's possible that did happen
in the eighteen hundreds but ideally
it would it would be a swift justice
they always say that with one
man i mean we've got 75 million trump
voters 80 million biden voters but it's
better than i think a totalitarian
dictatorship the threat of civil war is
better than a totalitarian dictatorship
the threat of civil war
it's better to know that there's a
possib like the the idea that a civil
war could happen means that the
dictatorship
is less likely to happen you always want
to reduce harm and
what usually reduces harm is individuals
being able to defend themselves
because people then don't take offensive
aggressive actions against them they say
an armed society is a polite society and
i think we're seeing that in places like
florida in places like texas where
people have the ability to protect
themselves unlike other jurisdictions
like chicago
new york city and a lot of the other big
cities where you can't and gang violence
and
uh has been skyrocketing because all the
gang members know people
are defenseless people can't defend
themselves if they do have a firearm but
now in many places
i think that in chicago you can't have a
gun but i i think it's really difficult
for i grew up there in the longest time
like all weapons were just outright
banned i think the only legal weapon
you're allowed to have is
is a rubber switch you know you know
what that is it's like a long piece of
rubber with a little ball at the end and
you whack people with it
what about a knife no knives that's
illegal yeah
in times square the biggest arrests that
were made were individuals that came in
from out of new york who had pocket
knives the biggest arrests that happened
i i forgot the exact statistic here but
but i i
heard a very wild one that the the
majority of arrests
in new york happen because of tourists
having guns on their
you know oh right yeah i imagine it's
like a knife of a certain length
yeah it's like longer than three and a
half inches or something so that's like
a pocket knife you get a certain pocket
knife
or maybe you've got like a utility knife
or something you carry around for
nail clippers yeah yeah and then they're
like well that's a crime
can't have that um alex do you know how
many
3d printed guns are in existence is that
even measurable um
not really i mean i broke 25 000 across
socials so i
imagine there's at least 25 000. um
i i would severe i would surely hope
that there are many many many times that
number
and i i believe that there are but i i
would have
no one there there's no way to count
because so most people are making them
in the privacy of their own home
and if they're doing it right they're
not telling anybody so we we were
talking about this
uh like last week i think about ghost
guns and some people were saying they
were illegal and then a bunch were like
no no they're totally legal
so ghost guns are legal is that correct
yeah so if you a minute ago we're
talking about like how you can
manufacture
any gun you manufacture at home for your
own personal use
is what politicians are calling a ghost
gun
like they're they are they're one the
same so it's not just 3d printed stuff
it's not just like the
the the 80 kits that you buy it's it's
anything that you're making at home
so what's how does the 80 kit work so uh
basically a cup a company when it said
uh
went to the atf and said hey is this
uh so okay i need a backup the atf
regulates
once one specific part of a firearm that
is the
as a firearm it's the serialized part
it's the one part that you actually have
to go to an ffl
a gun store to buy and what part is that
it varies based on
the firearm on a glock it's the polymer
frame
uh on an ar-15 it's the lower receiver
where the trigger
and the magazine go into um so that's
the serialized part
now what these 80 companies did is they
went to the etf and they had
a partially finished one they sent them
the the lawyer and said hey is this a
firearm yet
the atf said no so the the industry
called it an 80
complete firearm so it's not quite a
firearm
and you can you can buy it it ships
straight to your door and you finish it
on
basic tools uh there's a couple kits out
there one you do with like a a dewalt
router or something
some kind of just common hardware tool
or you can do it with a drill press
but then you still need to buy that last
piece right
wasn't there something going on where
people saying the atf was rating people
for having these kits
yeah so there was one specific kit done
by polymer 80 called the buy build shoot
kit
and they market it as everything you
need in a box to build a gun in a couple
hours
and you would click it once and you add
to the cart and they would ship it to
your door and then you'd spend an hour
putting it together and
the atf said that this box of parts that
weren't f that wasn't a firearm
was close enough to the definition of a
firearm
and market it in such a way that it
could be construed as a firearm that it
was actually a firearm
which doesn't make any sense right from
the legal perspective but this is the
etf we're talking about
they you know fairy dust and magic so in
terms of 3d printed guns you're printing
what like the frame the grip
the stock or what yeah basically any
external part
that has complex geometry so some things
that are going to be difficult to make
by hand
um and then looking specifically at like
the fgc 9
the barrel and the bolt are made at home
out of common common material um
and again the barrel uh we're we're
finishing it
with basically 3d printable inserts and
we're using electrochemical
machining to get the internal dimensions
of the barrel to the right size
and rifle it and cut the chamber and it
sounds really complicated it does i was
like what
yeah i know that shot really high for a
lot of people
but uh there's a good write-up on
it was auto playing a video from about
the ftc continue continue
anyway a lot of that went over a lot of
people's heads there's a really good
write-up it's
it sounds really complicated it's not
you're you've it's salt water and an
aquarium pump in a five gallon bucket in
your garage
so in total how much do you have to
spend on supplies materials
and everything you need to to make a
fgc9 okay
so the the hardware to get started the
printer itself
200 bucks yeah filament 40 bucks
the parts to build the actual gun your
internals
about another 200 bucks and then your
your
um your benchtop power supply and your
aquarium pump
to do the electrochemical machining is
like another 100 on top of that so when
you say electrochemical machining
right you have salt water in a tank how
does that work exactly so you
you're pumping water out of a bucket
salt water out of a bucket
through the inside of the barrel and
you've got a an electrode in the barrel
that's stripping material at the atomic
level awesome
off of the inside of the barrel to bore
it to the right size for your bullet
and then cut rifling and then cut in
your chamber wow
so that sounds really hard to do yes
it's not awesome it's not hard because
someone gave us a super chat a couple
days ago they're like no it's so easy
you could just print on
an fgc9 and i looked in i was like this
looks hard yeah this looks really hard
look it looks hard it's super easy um
what what caliber is after you see nine
it's a nine millimeter nine is that
where the nine comes from
yeah um yeah yeah and then the fcg
uh fgc means something else yeah f
gun control are there other printers
than the ender like uh next level
above the ender five um there are uh you
start to lose the value per dollar that
you're spending
so you can get into like a three or four
thousand dollar printer pretty quickly
what would be the value of that
uh i mean you're doing the same thing
you're doing on the under under five
does it print
about the same quality you might get an
upgraded materials
you might be able to print with some
fancy nylons and stuff like that
some higher temperature stuff but i mean
for the price difference
what about metal do you print metal no
so metal is a whole nother
manufacturing process and it's a lot
more to get into so
um there there's a couple different
methods of doing the most popular
the cheapest one and i'll start at this
is fifty thousand dollars
that you're spending to get in here wow
it's a laser that
melts a layer of powder and then the
printer scoops another layer on top of
it and
does another layer of melting those are
really fast though right no
it goes really smooth yeah it's pretty
wow um
and then once all that's done you have
to take that part you have to send it to
another company to do the final like
actually make it a solid part because
it's a bunch of particles that are stuck
together it's gotta go like a kiln or
something right
like heats and solidify something like
that yeah and then you have to add
material
physically add additional materials to
it so it becomes a lot more expensive a
lot more costly
there's applications for it but not for
like the home gunsmith i'm gonna do this
in my garage for the cheap
um like there are there are filaments
that have metal embedded in them but
they have the same problem
where it's just a bunch of medical metal
particles that are just
stuck together and then you have to send
it to another company to finish it
i got i got to be honest man you say it
sounds easy but i'm like looking at
these websites and it's just
there's hurdles to you know the average
person can't just do this yeah no
everything is a learning curve but uh
we've tried to make it really really
simple so
in order to get started i'm going to
plug my site go go to
theguide.controlpew.com
uh that'll get you your first 10 steps
into 3d printing
you're not 3d printing guns yet you're
just 3d printing you're just learning
how to use the printer
how to use the software how to get it
dialed in so it actually functions and
things fit together properly
and then the next step right find a gun
you want to print print it
and control p is c-t-r-l-e-w
c-t-r-l-p-e-w that's the guy dot
control-p dot com and just to clarify
uh having and making your own fgc nine
is legal federally
is that correct federally it's legal uh
state laws may vary i know
maryland has some funny business going
on i know california has funny business
going on
i know new york has funny business going
on well california and maryland
banned flamethrowers they're they're the
two
states and i know this because i own a
flamethrower they banned flamethrowers
which is just
utterly ridiculous and so in america i'm
sorry i thought this was america
people people are getting in trouble
with the the elon musk flamethrowers
yeah because people are buying them and
it's called not a flamethrower by the
boring company
and then people are getting the fed
string up the door being like that's a
flamethrower
the funny business is that's actually a
weed burner it's not a flamethrower it
just
has a little bit of flame that sits in
the end it doesn't throw the flame
everywhere and it's really depressing
and i'm really sad
about it and now now importantly making
your own 3d printed firearm like the
fgc9 is there any legislation against
doing this locally statewide is there
anything against 3d printing on the
books now because i've seen
individuals like chuck schumer who
literally
explain explain the black what was it
the silk road
in in such a way where it promoted it on
national television a few years ago now
talking about the ease of 3d printing
firearms there's a lot of
misunderstanding but but is there any
legislation proposed or or
on the books now against 3d printing
federally state or local
not at the federal level at the state
level like i said california maryland
new york i think there is some
legislation that exists
although how far you get with that i
don't know there's a couple people
um reno is a guy from a youtuber from
california
he's working on a 3d printed california
compliant
glock and ar-15 so
there are some specifics to work within
those sets of laws
but i'm not as well read on the
individual states to be able to answer
that with any level of competence
well you know even traveling with
firearms you you learn
about so many of the jurisdictions
reciprocities and
you literally need to hire a lawyer to
explain it to you because of the
different
made-up laws that each politician
interprets in their own unique ways
which is
again not universal and very confusing
and
leads a lot of people in trouble yeah
i'm so i'm so disappointed because i
tried
for like i sat for like three four hours
i dug through the law
to come out here with my trunk of fun
yeah and just show you guys what we're
working with and i couldn't do it
because i just couldn't figure out how
to navigate the whole thing properly and
i was like
okay i can't yeah i can't even begin
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you